Boston was never a city of kings or
conquerors the city's tallest building
long bore the name of a smuggler John
Hancock by the 19th century Boston was
trumping its intellectual ambitions as
the Athens of America but all that
learning was built on the wealth of a
solid mercantile base during the 20th
century America started to see the rise
of consumer cities places like Los
Angeles or Miami they grew because
people wanted to live there not because
firms had any particular reason to
choose that spot in a sense Boston was
America's first consumer city the
colonists who came to Massachusetts
during the 1620s and to Boston after
1630 were motivated by lifestyle choices
more than economics they wanted to live
in a Puritan society where they would be
free from persecution by English
authorities and would of course be free
to persecute others who didn't conform
to their own godly ways they wanted
Boston to shine as a city upon a hill as
John Winthrop reached aboard the Arbella
on his way to the city I recognize that
I'm displaying the standard economist
reductionism by referring to the desire
for eternal salvation as consumption but
well it certainly wasn't production
Boston had essentially no natural
economic advantages except for access to
abundant Cod and some pretty great
cranberry bogs consequently the first
few decades of Boston's existence were
spent trying to find a sustainable
economic model for the Bostonians needed
to import English manufactured goods
they needed guns they needed Bibles and
they didn't have all that much that was
worth shipping back across the Atlantic
Boston didn't have gold and silver
deposits like the Spanish colonies of
the south New England's climate is a bit
too much like the climate of Old England
which meant that Massachusetts couldn't
grow crops like sugar that were valuable
because they were rare back in Europe in
the early days Boston and Massachusetts
functioned it's something like a
colonial era Ponzi scheme which is
appropriate enough since Ponzi himself
was also a Bostonian each new wave of
settlers brought with them a bit of gold
the old settlers then sold food and land
to the new settlers and used the cash
that was paid to then pay for English
manufactured goods but like all Ponzi
schemes this one couldn't go on forever
and immigration to Massachusetts slowed
dramatically after 1640 the chaos of the
English Civil War slowed the migration
and cromwell's victory made it
unnecessary to cross the fierce Atlantic
to enjoy the pleasures of banning makeup
and restricting Christmas celebrations
so Bostonians needed a new business
model they tried a number of different
approaches john winthrop son founded an
ironworks that he hoped would provide a
valuable export industry he didn't
Boston's economic salvation came from
hunger in Barbados the Caribbean
colonies were cash cows Europeans would
pay a fortune for their sugar but the
land became so valuable that it didn't
pay to grow food there by 1647 Winthrop
had learned that Barbados planters were
and I quote so intent upon planting
sugar that they had rather buy food at
very dear rates than produce it by
labour so infinite is the profit of
sugar works so starting in the 1640s a
triangular trade began the more tropical
colonies would ship sugar and tobacco
back to Europe Boston would ship basic
commodities fish livestock wood products
to the southern colonies of the Americas
New Englanders would buy manufactured
goods with a cash earned by selling to
the sugar producing regions as late as
1770 73 percent of New England's exports
were going to the Caribbean into the
southern colonies 35% of those exports
were fish 31% were livestock at 21
percent was wood related Boston was one
hub of that triangle and also the
triangular trade and slaves that
developed simultaneously for a century
Boston thrived as the preeminent trading
hub of North America and the largest
city in the English colonies with 12,000
inhabitants in 1720 Boston's merchants
were smart and the city's sailors were
skilled but Boston had no natural lock
on this export model the cities of
Philadelphia and New York were further
south they each enjoyed a better river
network and a more fertile hinterland
Philadelphia's population surpassed that
of Boston after 1740 Boston's mid 18th
century economic doldrums led to some
pretty ordinary merchants including John
Hancock who took particular umbrage at
England's attempts to tax and limit
their trade their unhappiness was one of
the contributing factors that led to the
American Revolution but after that
revolution Boston soared once more and
once again its success reflected its
stock of water-related human capital the
decades after 1790 were an era of early
globalization America was freed from
trading restrictions and merchants
started buying bigger boats that were
people of sailing odyssey's they
traveled to Canton and South Africa they
cruised for whales in the Pacific Ocean
Boston slightly more northern location
mattered less when the ships were
traveling such long distances between
1790 and 1840 Boston's population
increased from 18,000 to 90,000 and its
economic strength was in the sea not
manufacturing as late as 1840 Boston had
10,000 workers in the maritime trades
and only 5000 in manufacturing which was
less than neighboring Lowell one center
of Massachusetts textile industry Boston
still shows the legacy of its commercial
strength during the era of sail the
wharves that still stand most notably
the Long Wharf itself were the Centers
of Commerce during that era small houses
close to the port like the still
standing home of Paul Revere were built
so that their residents could walk to
the wharves the old Statehouse a site on
Boston's Freedom Trail once held a
merchant's exchange in warehouses State
Street which was once King Street leads
right from that building down to the
wharf the city's large Irish population
is also a gift of Boston's dominance
during the era of sail desperate
immigrants could sail to Boston faster
than they could to New York during the
1840s and consequently Boston became a
major port of entry for those who are
fleeing the potato famine when the era
of sail was replaced by the era of steam
New York's maritime dominance became
almost complete and subsequent
immigrants would come overwhelmingly to
Ellis Island not Boston as a consequence
New York would become a dizzying ethnic
mix while Boston was still dominated by
the divide between Irish and Yankee
Boston's merchants did many great things
they fought for liberty which was so
valuable for their financial livelihoods
they built the infrastructure including
rail lines that would help Boston
reinvent itself once again during the
industrial era they invested in colleges
and universities after World War two
those academic institutions especially I
hate to admit MIT provided new
entrepreneurial energy for the region
Boston may not have the great palaces or
monuments of Imperial cities like Vienna
or Paris but it remains a handsome city
displaying the wealth that its merchants
earned by using their wits to trade with
the world
you